[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم لطالما شكلت قصه الخوذ البيضاء
في اتول الثوره السوريه قضيه عالميه مثيره
للجدل فالمدنيون المتطوعون لانقاذ الضحايا
السوريين من قصف البراميل والمتفجرات
والكيماوي اصبحوا ارهابيين وعملاء وجواسيس
الامريكان حسب الدعايه الرسميه السوريه
والروسيه في عام واحد لكنها من زاويه
اصحابها قصه البطوله الاستثنائيه والعمل
الميداني الشاق الذي كان السبيل الوحيد
لانقاذ الشعب الاعزل في مواجهه الاله
العسكريه الشرسه ويوميات القتل بلا حدود
طوال اعوام ثوره الشعب السوري استعرض
الليله قصه الشاب الذي خرج من مدينته جسر
الشغور لاجئا الى جنوب تركيا بعد اجتياح
عام 2012 من قبل الجيش السوري واستطاع من
المخيم وبعد حصوله على التدريب في اعمال
الانقاذ والاجلاء ثم عودته الى المدينه
المنكوبه استطاع ان يؤسس لفريق كبير من
المتطوعين الس يعملون في انقاذ ابناء
شعبهم مما يتعرضون له كبرت العمليه شيئا
فشيئا وتم تنظيمه وتوحيد الجهود حتى جاء
اطلاق مؤسسه الدفاع المدني السوري لينضوي
تحت لوائها الاف من الشباب والمجموعات
العامله في مجال الانقاذ يقول مؤسسها ان
عمليه التوثيق للجرائم المرتكبه والرغبه
بقتل الشهود ومحو اثار تلك الجرائم كانت
السبب وراء الحملات الكبرى ضد اصحاب الخوذ
البيضاء الليله رائد الصالح رئيس مؤسسه
الدفاع المدني السوري وحديث مفصل عن
التجربه والدعم والالام التي تعرض لها
السوريون في محن التشريد والهجمات
والجائحه الصحيه كورونا واخيرا كارثه
الزلزال كل هذا في المقابله هذا المساء
فاهلا ومرحبا بكم
[موسيقى]
الشاب الذي تؤرق تجربته الشخصيه وتجربه
المنظمه مسيره الثوره السوريه في العوامل
الماضيه 12 سنه الماضيه صحيح يعني اكيد
هذا شرف كتير كبير انه الوصف بهذه الطريقه
يعني الثوره السوريه اكيد اكبر من انه انا
مثلها لانه يعني هي ثوره شعب عظيم عمل
المنظمه كان يعني مستمر على مدى حياه
المنظمه لانه هي فينا نقول انه المنظمه هي
بدات كفرق تطوعيه اصلا يعني الفرق
التطوعيه بدات من سوريا اللي هي فلين
انبثقت من التنسيقيات ومن
المؤسسات اللي كانت تعمل في المناطق اللي
خارج عن سيطره النظام وقت اللي هي فعليا
فينا نقول وقت بدا النظام السوري يستخدم
سياسه العقاب الجماعي ضد المجتمعات اللي
خرجت بمظاهرات لانه وقت اللي سحب كل
الخدمات سحب كل الفرق الاطفاء فرق الانقاذ
من كل هاي المناطق الشعب اعزل في وصار
يقصفوا هاي المناطق بلش سياسه العقاب
الجماعي على اثره تشكلت هاي الفرق اللي
هني من شباب بلشت تساعد الناس باللي
بتعرفه اين ومتى ولد رائد الصالحة يعني
انا
مواليد واحد ثلاثه اربعه وثمانين من مدينه
جسر الشهور ولدت في هاي المدينه اللي هي
فعليا مصدومه على مدى عقد طويل من الزمن
متزوج عندي طفلين
يعني كم عمرك في 2011 ب 2011 كان عمري لم
تتم الثلاثين يعني ما كانت
اقل من 30 كان تقريبا
هذا الشاب الذي وجد نفسه فجاه
امام هذه الكارثه الكبرى امام هذه الثوره
العظيمه امام هذه الماسي ذكرني بهذه
اللحظه رائد التي وجدت نفسك فيها في خدم
هذه الاحداث حياه ما فيني اقول انه انا
يعني الماساه هي ما بلشت بالفين كان في
حراك وكان الناس متفائله جدا بعمليه تغيير
ممكن تنقل سوريا لمرحله لدوله مزدهره
ودوله متطوره ولكن مع استمرار سياسه
العقاب الجماعي النظام السوري يستخدم نفس
السياسه بتذكر لهلا اول مدينه يعني احنا
اقتحم مدينتنا الجيش السوري 20 الف عسكري
بايداع السته 2011 وانا تقريبا هون اضطريت
كل المدينه دخلت اتجاه تركيا وكانت ايام
عصيبه في بدايه نزوحنا واقمت مع عائلتي في
احد المخيمات على حدود السوريه التركيه في
جنوب تركيا على الحدود السوريه التركيه
كنت في احد المخيمات اقمت لفتره يعني
تقريبا خمس سنين ولكن بعد مرو عده اشهر من
من هذا العمل من من اقامه المخيم بدات
مناطق على الحدود تخرج عن سيطره النظام
وهون بدات الناس تلجا لهاي المناطق من
المدن ومن الارياف فنحن كنا في هذا المخيم
نجمع المساعدات من هذا المخيم وننزلهم
باتجاه الحدود سوريه باتجاه الطرف السوري
ونعطيهم للمدنيين بعد بحكم العلاقه مع
المسؤولين بالمخيم وانا كنت من اداره من
لجنه اللي مسؤوله عن المخيم
فشكلنا اول شيء المكتب الاغاثي لجسر
الشغور وريفا وكنا ندعم المدنيه الموجودين
هذا بشهر شباط 2012 تقريبا بداتوا
تستوعبون ان ثمه كارثه بدات تتضح ملامحها
نعم بدات يعني هون النزوح وبدات التهجير
بعد تشكيل هذا المكتب بفتره كان هناك يعني
تدريب للدفاع المدني تدريب للبحث والانقاذ
في اسطنبول
فعندما ذهبنا في اول تدريب
فيني يقول هو النواه لادلب وليس لسوريا من
من اشرف على التدريب ما هي خطه التدريب
هلا التدريب الاول كان
التمويل هو فعليا كان من الحكومه
البريطانيه وكان هو لمنظمي تركيه اسمها
اكوداما هي مختصه في البحث والانقاذ وكانت
تعاون بشكل مباشر بهذاك الوقت مع مجلس
محافظه ادلب احنا خرجنا باتجاه 2013 هذا
الوقت كان تجاهنا باتجاه اسطنبول وفعليا
التدريب فيني يقول هو نقطه التحول انا
بعملي لانه المدرب التركي عندما استقبلنا
في مركز التدريب صار يدخلنا اثنين اثنين
بمكان مظلم وفي كثير من الطاولات والكراسي
وقال في باب اخر لازم تطلعوا منه فكنا نحن
ندخل 2 2 بهذا الباب وقت طلعنا من الباب
الاخر
قلنا شو شفتوا جوا فقالوا يعني شو قدرنا
نطلع بدون ما نوقع في طاولات في كراسي فهو
رجعنا على الغرفه على القاعه واشغل الضوء
وقال كان في طبعا من المدربين نفسه تحت
الطاولات والكراسي قال هذا الفرق ما بين
الشخص المتدرب والغير متدرب كيف بقدر بشوف
الناس تحت الانقاض بدون ما يعرف هو بالاصل
قبل ما يجي وينها الحقيقه هون كانت صدمه
يعني
كانت صدمه يعني
يعني بلشنا مثل انه نتواصل مع بعضنا بعدين
بالتعاون مع المنظمه الداعمه اللي هي كانت
ميديا واللي هي كانت تتمول من قبل حكومات
غربيه
وقالوا طرحنا انه نحن لازم نعمل مؤتمر لكل
الفرق اللي بتشتغل بكل سوريا
وانا من ضمنهم يعني من هدول الاثنين
اجتمعنا في اضنه هي 25 اكتوبر 2014 تقريبا
بعد سنه وثلاثه اشهر من تدريبي انا اللي
تلقيته اول تدريب تناقشنا لمده ايام شو هي
القيم شو هي المبادئ ليش نحن عم نشتغل ليش
بدنا نعمل شو بدنا نسوي شو هي التجارب
الدنيا كيف صارت يعني درسنا بالخليج كيف
والاوروبا بامريكا بتركيا كيف انه منظمه
هاي الامور فعليا توصلنا اخر انه نحن لازم
ناسس بظل كان في في صراع يعني سياسي كثير
كبير بسوريا انه نحن لا لازم ناسس نعرف
انه هذا الشغل بكل دول العالم هو مرتبط مع
الحكومات يكون تابع للحكومات لكن نحن
مضطرين ناسس شيء مستقل
يقدر يقدم نفس الخدمات بالطريقه
طبعا نطاق الحكومه النظام السوري الحكومه
الرسمي ذاك الوقت وخارج ايضا الفصائل
والجماعات السياسيه المعارضه صح يعني
فعليا نحن كنا خارج ولكن نحن
وقعنا بخمسه وعشرين عشره وقعنا ميثاق
المبادئ اللي هو بنص على تاسيس هاي
المؤسسه وفعلا كان من ضمن ميثاق المبادئ
انه هاي المؤسسه هي مؤسسه حياديه وبتخدم
كل السوريين ولا تنتمي لاي حزب سياسي او
المدني الدفاع المدني السوري وكان لها
شعار واحد وبعدين وضعنا اول نظام داخلي
وعلى اساس انه باعتبار يعني كان مثل ما
التحدي انه كيف بده يصير مين بده يعين
مدير الدفاع المدني مين بدي يعين
المسؤولين بالمناطق لانه نحن كنا نشتغل
بدرعا كنا بدمشق كنا هناك
قررنا انه راح يكون في عنا اليه انتخابيه
داخل المؤسسه هاي الاليه هي بتنتخب مجلس
الاداره ومجلس الاداره بيشرف على 2014
اعلنت عن تاسيس الدفاع المدني السوري ب
25/10/2014 شو يعني الانتقال الكبير اللي
حصل بعد الاعلان هلا بعد الاعلان صار في
تواصل يعني بالاعلان كان حضرانين المعارضه
السوريه وكانت حضران الائتلاف وكان
حضرانين الدول كتير داعمه كانت بتدعم
السوريين بهذاك الوقت الانتقال صار انه
صار في لقاءات اول شيء عملناه بصراحه كان
فقط من كل المحافظات التسعه اللي كنا
شكلنا هاي المؤسسه كان في ادلب وحلب تتلقى
تمويل بشكل مستقل
واجتمعنا بادلب وحلب قاده المسؤولين بادلب
وحلب بالدفاع المدني قبل ما نصير مؤسسه
وحده قلنا لهم نحن وصلنا يعني ما كان عنا
تمويل ابدا بدنا وصلنا 94 الف دولار نحن
لازم نتخذ قرار باعتبار صرنا مؤسس وحدي
لازم يتوزعوا على كل سوريا فعليا 94 هدول
اول اول تمويل كاش بيوصل
يعني هلا انا بقول لك
اول الداعمين كان هو تدريب ومعدات هلا اول
اول اول دوله قدمت معدات فحص وانقاذ كانت
لمدينه حلب كانت اليو اس اي اللي هي
الوكاله الامريكيه للتنميه وبعدين صار
التمويل ايضا نحن تلقينا تمويل عن طريق
الحكومه البريطانيه ولكن عن طريق مؤسسات
وسيطه فبعد انضمت هولندا الدنمارك
وقطر انضمت ب 2017 للتمويل ايضا ويعني ده
احنا دائما في مفاوضات دائما تدخل دول
وتطلع دول يعني
الاعداد اولا 2011 لحد 2013 نحن 2019
ما كنا منظمين يقول 2013 كانت فرق هي يعني
نحن كنا بادلب تقريبا حوالي 70 75 واحد في
2013 2014 صرنا حوالي 200 300 شخص في حلب
كان تقريبا 400 مجمل كنا تقريبا ب 2014
واتوقعنا ميثاق المبادئ كان العدد حوالي
2800 ولكن مع مرور الوقت ب 2017 وصل العدد
4800 ولحنا تراجع العدد
3,170 تقريبا بسبب انه نحن خسرنا كتير من
المناطق اللي عم نشتغل فيها لانه كنا
نشتغل
بتسع محافظات بتسع مناطق بدمشق كنا نشتغل
بريف دمشق بدرعا القنيطره حمص حلب ادلب
حماه
وحتى الرقه
في مناطق كتير خسرناها مع خساره سيطره
النظام على هاي المناطق نحن كنا كان
يتنازل العدد وكان
فعليا تنخفض الاعداد والارقام استاذ رائد
سعيد جدا بوجودك شخصيا واعتقد انك لعبت
دورا مهما في في هذه المسيره واعتقد
المنظمه لعبت دورا ونتساءل عن الخوذ
البيضاء وهذه التسميه والحرب التي وجهت
بهذه المنظمه ومسيره الثوره السوريه بشكل
عام الذي كانت موازيه لعملكم سنتحدث كل
هذا عن كل هذه المواضيع على الطاوله التي
تجمعنا مرحبا بك في المقابله
[موسيقى]
ربما لم تلقى منظمه انسانيه على عرض
السوريه اثناء سنوات الثوره هناك تشويها
لسمعتها او تحريفا لدورها الانساني كالذي
لقيته منظمه الدفاع المدني السوري او
الخوذ البيضاء اخذ دور المنظمه التي جرى
تاسيسها عام 2013 يتعاظم بعد ان تحولت
الثوره الى نزاع مسلح اودى بمقتل زهاء نصف
مليون شخص واجبر اكثر من 13 مليون شخص اما
للفرار خارج البلاد او النزوح داخل حدودها
المنظمه التي اطلق عليها اسم الخوذ
البيضاء اعتبارا من عام 2014 تمحور دورها
حول اسعاف الجرحى ودفن القتلى وازاله
الانقاض جراء هجمات قوات النظام السوري
وحلفائه
وتعمل المنظمه في نطاق المناطق التي تسيطر
عليها قوات المعارضه في الشمال السوري ومن
ثم داب النظام السوري على اتهامها بانها
اداه في ايدي المانحين الامر الذي نفته
المنظمه جمله وتفصيلا مؤكده الاستقلاليتها
وحيادها وغياب ارتباطها باي جهه سياسيه
وبرزت منظمه الخوذ البيضاء كذلك اثناء
كارثه الزلزال الذي ضرب جنوب تركيا وشمال
سوريا اوائل فبراير من العام الجاري معززه
بخبراتها السابقه في مواجهه العمليات
العسكريه عدد المنتسبين الى المنظمه وصل
الى نحو ثلاثه الاف وثلاث مئه متطوع قتل
منهم 300 خلال سنوات الحرب واربعه اثناء
الزلزال وقادت الجهود الانسانيه لمنظمه
القوه البيضاء الى الترشيحها لنيل جائزه
نوبل للسلام في عام 2016 وهي وان كانت لم
تحصل عليها فقد نالت في العام نفسه جائزه
المنظمه السويديه الخاصه
لحقوق الانسان التي تعد بديلا لنوبل كما
حصل فيلم وثائقي انتج في العام 2017
وتناول جهود الخوض البيضاء على جائزه
الاوسكار لافضل فيلم الوثائقي
البيضاء متى من هذا الاسم اصبح كانه ماركه
براند عالمي يعني حياتنا يعني كمان تحدثنا
قبل شوي انه نحن وقت اساسنا اسسنا الدفاع
المدني السوري ليكون مظله وطنيه لكل فرق
البحث الانقاذ بسوريا واللي هي عم تدعم
اهلها بسوريا
مع بدايه 2015 تصور فيديو للطفل المعجزي
بنسميه احنا الملك البيبي اللي هو فعليا
بعد تم انقاذه بعد 16 ساعه عمل بمدينه حلب
بعد برميل متفجر ما نزل على بيتهم بعد 16
ساعه عمل تم انقاذ هذا الطفل
وفعلا تم تصوير هذا الفيديو والترجم للغه
الانجليزيه وانتشر بشكل كثير كبير بالعالم
وطبعا الفريق تبعنا هو اللي بعد 16 ساعه
عمل قدر يطلع هذا الطفل كان عمره سبعه
ايام تقريبا والطفل ما زال الا الان على
قيد الحياه حوالي هلا صار تقريبا صف ثالث
بالمدرسه
وانتشر هذا الفيديو بشكل كثير كبير حياتنا
وهذا الشيء خلى انه الناس صارت تسمينا برا
الوايت يعني حتى في البدايه نحن
كنا نقول لا نحن الدفاع المدني احنا مالنا
الوايت بس
نعم
الخواد البيضاء لكن مع مرور الوقت حقيقه
هذا الاسم هو صار مثل ما قلت هو صفه لانه
وين ما رحنا بالعالم وصارت الخوذه هي اصلا
ترمز للسلام وترمز للمدنيه السوريه اللي
هي فعليا عم تناضل من اجل تحقق حقوقه
وتعيد الحقوق للضحايا اللي تم استهدافهم
عبر كل السنوات الماضيه طيب هناك حرب
ومواجهه شرسه كبيره جدا وحقيقه حرب غير
متكافئه وغير متساويه بين نظام مدعوم من
جهات دوليه يمارس عمليات تفجير وتدمير
وبين مؤسسه مدنيه اريد ان اؤرق لهذه
المواجهه اول واهم محطات المواجهه بينكم
وبينها حياه يعني نحن
الهدف كان انه فعليا نحن نوجد مؤسسه تخدم
الناس
ونحقق الحلم اللي نحن كنا عم نحلم فيه انه
فعليا المؤسسات الدوله او مؤسسات السوريه
تكون هي بخدمه السوريين وليس السوريين
بخدمه المؤسسات تكون العمليه معكوسه على
الشيء اللي تربينا عليه ب 50 سنه الماضي
كان المواطن في خدمه مواطن دائما بخدمه
النظام وكان هو متسلط عليه بكل الطرق نحن
حاولنا نعكس هاي الايه وهذا الشيء هي
فعليا مبادئ والقيم اللي تاسست عليها او
اللي قامت عليها الثوره السوريه
نحن اللي حاولنا
مع مرور الوقت اول عمليه بصراحه الاستهداف
كانت مستمر ما في عنا حالات مواجهه يعني
في نقاط لكن فيني اقول اول تدخل روسيا هو
كان الحرب الاكبر علينا
2015 هي اول استهداف لروسيا استشهد شاب من
الدفاع المدني
بفرن كان عم يطفوا فرن بعد استهداف اول
بمدينه الرسام كان عم يطفوا فرن واستهدفت
روسيا بالاستهداف الثاني وكان هذا الكلام
بواحد تسعه الشاب عبد الله ضحيك بمدينه
الرستن هون استاذ رائد صار في تحول يعني
كان النظام هو الذي يقوم بالعمليات الان
دخلت دوله عظمى شو اللي تغير الحقيقه اللي
تغير بعد دخول روسيا على على سوريا انه
صارت الحرب علينا ما بس حرب على الارض
وانما حرب على المستوى الدولي يعني بعد
بعد استهداف استهداف لفريق الدفاع المدني
بمدينه بناحيه احسن بجبل الزاويه واستشهد
فيها ابن عمي بهذا الهجوم وبعد بعد صار في
عنا استهداف لمركزنا بكفر زياده استشهد من
متطوعين
بالادارب اربع متطوعين صار في استهداف
لاستراتيجيه عسكريه عم تستهدف الخوذ
البيضاء ليش فعليا مثل ما بتعرف يعني اي
مجرم بالعالم بده يرتكب جريمه اول شيء
بيعمله هو بيخفي المعالم الجريمه او بيقتل
الشاهد اذا في شاهد حدا شافه
نحن شفنا هاي الجرائم وثقنا هاي الجرائم
لذلك كانوا عم يحاولوا هني يقتلوا الخوذ
البيضاء ولكن تعرفوا ان الخوذ البيضاء هو
جزء صار صارت هي جزء من الهويه السوريه
بدات بدات تتغير الحرب علينا وبدات تروح
باتجاه التضليل والتشويه السمعه فانه ما
قدرت اقتله شوه سمعته وبفقدوا المصداقيه
عفوا انت تقول دخلنا في منطقه توثيق يعني
انتم تقومون بعمل اغاثه وعمل توثيقي كيف
كانت تم عمليه توثيق هلا كل عمليات
التوثيق بالدفاع المدني هي بتم عن طريق
الكاميرات الموجوده على الخواس كل كل فريق
بحسه انقاص كل فريق اطفاء موجود بالخوذ
البيضاء هن في عندهم كاميرات في عنده هذا
الفريق واحد منهم بيكون في كاميرا
مركبه على على الخوزي هي بتوثق كل
العمليات وكل الاستهدافات اللي بتصير هاي
العمليات بصراحه هاي التوثيق هذا ساهم
بكشف كثير من الجرائم وتوثيق كثير من
الجرائم واصدار كتير من التقارير لذلك
تحولت انه انا ما بقدر بقتل الشاهد بضرب
مصداقيه الشاهد هنا كان
وحده مواجهه على الارض اللي هي الضربات
المزدوجه انه يقصف الموقع حتى ياتي فريق
الخوذ البيضاء ثم يقصف مره اخرى
واستهدافهم بشكل مباشر والمسار الثاني
اللي هو التشوير خلني ابدا بالمواجهه على
الارض ما حجم وبشاعه وشراسه هذه الحياه
نحن وجهنا بكل الطرق يعني اولا من
الاستهداف المباشر للمراكزنا واللي تم
تدمير عدد كبير منها بسبب القصف الروسي
الاستهداف المباشر للمتطوعين اللي هن
فعليا مثل ما ذكرت قبل شوي
بكفر زيتا في ثمان متطوعين
بالاثارب في اربع متطوعين بحلب بالغوطه
الشرقيه
بعمليات الاغتيال اغتيل قائد الخوذه
البيضاء بريف دمشق اغتيل قائد القوات
البيضاء بدرعا عمليات التصفيه ب 12 انا
الى الان هذا التاريخ لا يمكن انساه
بحياتي ب 12/8 او 11/8 ب 2017
الان في عمليه اغتيال لكل مركز كامل دخله
تم اغتيال مركز في مدينه سرمين
دخلوا على المركز وتم تصفيه كل
في هذه المدينه هي بجنوب ادلب باربعه كيلو
متر هي قريبه من ادلب تم الدخول الى مركز
دفاع مدني وتصفيه من متطوعين بشكل مباشر
ايضا بعدها بحوالي عده اشهر ايضا ريف حلب
الجنوبي ايضا تم الدخول الى المركز وتصفيظ
المتطوعين بشكل مباشر فكنا نتعرض لكثير من
الضغوطات حتى يتم اثناء القوات البيضاء
نعم يعني ايضا تعتقد انه مساله التوثيق
ادت الى
هنا كان هو عمليه تخويف يعني عمليه القتل
والاستهداف هي لزرع الخوف في قلوب
المتطوعين الدفاع المدني حتى يتوقفوا عن
العمل حتى يتوقفوا عن المحطات اللي كانت
صعبه على على منظمه الدفاع المدني السوري
اصعب المحطات في المواجهه يعني دائما
المواجهه يعني نحن اولا يعني المواجهه هي
دائما كانت صعبه ولكن عندما يعني هنا
منظمه مدنيه سوريه تواجه ثاني دوله عظمى
بالعالم هي تمتلك من المقومات ومن كل شيء
فهي جندت حتى حسابات المزيفه على تويتر
حتى تكتب علينا حتى في لحظات الزرويه يتم
نشر خمس حوالي 500 الف تغريدي عن مواضيع
تشوه سمعه الخواذ البيضاء حتى وصلوا الى
شراء زمن بعض البروفيسورات في اوروبا
وبريطانيا هناك تقرير ايضا للكتابه عن
كتابه ابحاث عن الخوذه البيضاء بانهم
يضللون معلومات
ابرز حقيقه
الامور
المواجهه نحن كنا نواجه دائما ما يسالوني
كيف تواجهون روسيا نحن نواجه روسيا
والنظام بالحقيقه نحن لا يوجد لدينا اسلحه
الا الحقيقه التي نحن شهود عليها ونحن من
نمتلك الحقيقه بالجرائم التي ارتكبتها
روسيا والنظام ولكن حقيقه اكثر شيء صادم
كان بالنسبه لنا عندما وصل الامر بروسيا
الى ان تطالب بجلسه لمجلس الامن لاخراج
الخوذ البيضاء من سوريا حقيقه كان يعني
هنا نحن شعلنا بزهول بانه دوله كيف تمارس
الكذب والتضليل والانتهاكات بنفس الوقت
ولكن نحن تحدثنا كثيرا يعني تحدثنا بكل
انحاء العالم وتحدثنا
بفزوريه وبكل ولكن كنا نتعرض دائما لضغوط
كبيره جدا التي تعرضت لها الخوذه البيضاء
احنا نعرف انه تصدرت المشهد في سنوات 16
صدرت واجهه الاهداف على ماذا تسترد ماذا
ماذا يقولون عن الخوض البيضاء انا اقصد
الطرف الروسي والطرف التابع له يعني انا
دعني اقول يعني نحن لدينا تقريبا 16 تهمه
اتهمتنا بهاروسيا
يعني ابرزها باننا عملاء للمخابرات
الامريكيه عملاء المخابرات البريطانيه
عملاء المخابرات السعوديه عملاء المخابرات
القطريه عملاء المخابرات التركيه عملاء
نحن داعش نحن
النصره نحن
نساند الجماعات المسلحه يعني حقيقه كل هذه
جمله الى تجاره الاعضاء البشريه الى
نقل الاسلحه الكيميائيه الى استخدام
الاسلحه الكيميائيه كل هذه
يقبل من طرف وطني ان يتهم طرف اخر حتى وان
كانت بالعماله لكن طرف اجنبي يتهم طرف
وطني بانه عماله يعني كانت لافته شوي يعني
حقيقه انها كل هذه الاتهامات نحن اتهمنا
بها يعني حتى وصلتم علاقتكم مميزه
بالامريكان
[موسيقى]
الكاتب في تركيا في لدينا مكاتب ايضا في
اوروبا وفي كندا ويعني نمتلك ميزانيه
الدفاع المدني تقريبا السنويه بالحالات
قبل الزلزال بدون الزلزال فهي ميزانيه
تقريبا حوالي 19 الى 20 مليون دولار
بالسنه من صاحب المساهمه الاكبر فيها لا
يوجد صاحب مساهمه اكبر حقيقه هناك الامر
يختلف من من بلد الى اخر ومن سنه الى اخرى
هناك مساهمات دائما تاتي من قبل دول نحن
دائما لدينا الماستر او المضجت العامه
الميزانيه العامه للمؤسسه ونحن نناقش
الدول ونطرح عليهم الميزانيه تاتي دوله
معينه انه انا ساغطي هذا القسم من مثلا
ساغطي برنامج نحن لدينا اربع برامج رئيسيه
مع المدني البرنامج الاول هو برنامج البحث
والانقاذ الذي والاطفاء الذين معروفين به
كثيرا البرنامج الثاني هو برنامج
وهو يغطي منظومه اسعاف فنحن نمتلك منظومه
اسعاف 140 سياره اسعاف تعمل على الارض
مقدم 13 عمليه وسطيا في سنه 2022 عدد
عملات اسعاف التي ينفذها شهريا 13,500
عمليه اسعاف بالاضافه الى مراء 39 مركز
للاسره
للمراه والاسره اللي هي نستقبل اكثر من
عشره الاف شخص شهريا من النساء والاطفال
ونقدم لهم خدمات
الصحه الايجابيه واهدمات التغذيه الاطفال
اضافه لخدمات الاسعافات الاوليه بالاضافه
للتوعيه المخلفات الحرب والامراض
الدول العربيه
البرنامجين الاخرين
البرنامج الثالث وهو برنامج دعم صمود
المجتمعات وهو نعتمد بشكل كبير على دعم
اهلنا بشكل مباشر من خلال
ازاله مخلفات الحرب ندعم المزارعين نزوين
مخلفات الحرب مساهم بدعم
الامن الغذا في المنطقه حيث تزيين
المخالفات الحرب ومساعد المزارعين على
استصلاح اراضيهم والعمل بها وايضا نعمل
مشروع الاخر هو الخدمات المدنيه
نقدم الاصلاح شبكات المياه الكهرباء
الطرقات نفتح
القنوات المياه ايضا مشروع
الاطفاء هناك اطفاء ايضا الزراعي الذي
نحافظ من خلاله على البيئه على الغابات
وعلى المزروعات في فتره الحصاد لو تعلم
وخاصه يعني كان هذا برز اهميه هذا العمل
بعد الحرب الروسيه على اوكرانيا البرنامج
الرابع هو برنامج توثيق
الانتهاكات في ضد النظام وروسيا وهو يعني
يوثق كل الانتهاكات ويوثق ايضا الانتهاكات
بالاسلحه
منظمات مؤسسات مجتمع المدني في اشتراطات
ايدولوجيه عليها يعني هم لا يدعمون اي جهه
يخشون من لون ايدولوجيه شلون من انتماءات
ماء هل اثر هذا الامر دفع باتجاه
خلينا نقول فكري معين ايدولوجي معين تبنى
موقف معين هلا الدفاع المدني السوري هو
تبنى هويه وطنيه من لحس التاسيس وتبنى انه
سيكون من ظل وطني هو لم ينتمي لحزب سياسي
او لدولوجيا معينه هو قال له كلمه بانه هو
من الشعب وللشعب السوري نحن نقدم كل فئه
نقدم كل فئات الشعب فنحن يعني لا يمكن انت
كفريق فحص ان تسال شخص تحت الانقاذ تاكل
ما هو طائفتك وما هي قوميتك ولمن تنتمي
نحن نساعد كل السوريين بغض النظر عن
انتماءاتهم الطائفيه والعرقيه والقوميه
ونقدم بصراحه خدماتنا في كل المناطق نحن
التي نستطيع الوصول اليها في علاقتكم
بالفصائل المسلحه التي تتولى السيطره في
المناطق المعارضه السوريه وهي الفصائل
معدلجه لها هويه يعني هو فكريه حقيقه على
مدى من تاسيس الدفاع المدني الى الان مرت
كثير من الفصائل هناك فصائل كانت تصعد
فصائل تزول وفصائل تستلم مكانها الدفاع
المدني من نزول اللحظه الاولى لتاسيسه كان
يعمل على استقلاليته وكان يحافظ على
استقلاليته تحت اقصى الضغوط التي كان
يتعرض لها من قبل كثير من المناطق فنحن
حافظنا على استقلاليه هذه المؤسسه حتى
نستطيع ونستمر بتقديم الخدمات لاهلنا
المدنيين وهناك كثير يعني تعرضنا في بعض
الاحيان سابقا لضغوطات في بعض المناطق
ولكن نحن حاليا فعليا لم نكن نردق لك تلك
الضغوطات وكان كلام واضح باننا نحن سنخدم
ان انت ضغطت علي انا يعني سانسحب لا لا
املك شيء واجه به الا نحن لذلك نحن لدينا
الان يعني حاضنه اجتماعي كبير وهذه
الحاضنه الاجتماعيه هي حصن وامان
للدفاع المدني حتى يستمر بعمله استهداف
الكيماوي كان تحدي ايضا لا شك انه اكبر
التحديات التي واجهها الدفاع المدني هو
استخدام الاسلحه الكيميائي ضد المدنية
واكبر هجوم كيميائي نحن استجبنا له اكبر
هجومين كان في 2017 في خان شيخون و 2018
في مدينه دوما وكان هناك تحدي كبير ليس
فقط بتقديم استجابه لانه نحن يعني في ليس
فقط مقدم استجاب بل سنعمل على تقديم توثيق
توثيق هذه الانتهاكات فنحن نعتبر المنظمه
المدني الوحيده في العالم التي استجابت لي
هجمات على هذا الامر نعم نحن
تلقينا تدريبات على الاستجابه طبعا
تدريبات بعد هجوم خان شيخون وليس قبل هجوم
كان شيخون بعد هجوم خان شيخون يعني نحن
طالبنا بتدريبات
على ماذا بالضبط على يعني عندما يكون هناك
هجوم على بالاسلحه الكيميائيه ماذا نفعل
في هذا الوقت
كيف نستطيع ان نقدم الاسعافات الاوليه
لانه بعد هجوم خان شيخون واستشهاد عدد
كبير من المدنيين وسقوط عدد كبير من
الضحايا هذا كان يتطلب نوع جديد من
الاستجابه للدفاع المدني هذا وقعنا في
يعني
توثيقكم لحجم
الخسائر حقيقه
وما نتج عن هذا الاستهداف الكرام الثاني
على الاقل يعني نحن دعنا بعد التدريب
الفرق نحن عملنا مع منظمه حظر الاسلحه
الكيميائيه التي هي كانت تحقق في استخدام
الاسلحه الكيميائيه في سوريا بعد التوثيق
هذه الانتهاكات تم تقديم الادله والعينات
الفيزيائيه والشهود على استخدام هذه
الاسلحه في سوريا وفعليا بعد عمل وثيق مع
المنظمه حظر السلاح الكيميائيه استطعنا
يعني تقديم ادله كافيه لاثبات ان النظام
السوري استخدم الاسلحه الكيميائيه في خان
شيخون واستخدم الاسلحه الكيميائيه في دوما
وقبلها في مناطق اخرى وهذا الطرح حقيقه
يعني نستذكر
28/10/2017 عندما صدر التقرير التحقيق من
اللجنه التحقيق المشتركه في التابعه لمجلس
الامن بانه النظام السوري هو من استخدام
الاسلحه الكيميائي في خان روسيا استخدمت
سبع مرات حق النقض الفيتو وهذا ما يحدث في
موضوع دخول المساعدات فنحن شاهدنا كيف بان
روسيا دائما ما تستخدم حق النقد الفيتو
لعبور المساعدات للمدنيين بشمال غرب سوريا
وتستخدمه بشكل مستمر الحقيقه هناك
استثنائيه في الالام التي تعرض لها
السوريون بدا من 2011 طبعا ما قبل 2011
بكثير لكن من 2011 حجم المعاسي والكوارث
والتهجير والقتل والتشريد وما الى ذلك ثم
استهداف باسلحه بالبراميل والكيماوي
ثم جاءت كورونا
وملايين من اللاجئين السوريين اذا كان هذا
تحدي كبير يعني اكبر تحديا الكورونا
والزلزال الاخير ابدا بكورونا وهذه الازمه
الجائحه الصحيه الكبيره هل كانت مؤلمه على
الشعب السوري اللاجئ في المخيمات يعني
حقيقه الكورونا هي لا شك هي الكوفيد 19
وجميع من في العالم تالم من هذا الفيروس
ولكن السوريين يعني
في البدايه واجهنا صعوبات في موضوع
التوعيه يعني تكلمنا نحن كنا عندما نتحدث
بانه
يعني هذا الفيروس هو فيروس قاتل يقول
نرمين بدي موت
ولكن واجهنا صعوبه كبيره وحقيقه طريق
التعاطي الامم المتحده والمنظمه الصحه
العالميه مع سوريا هذا زاد من معاناه
الشعب السوري في في شمال غرب سوريا تحديدا
في المخيمات لانها اوصلت المساعدات الخاصه
بكوفيد 19 الى النظام السوري قبل ان
توصلها الى المخيمات بشهرين هذا اضطرنا
بالقوه البيضاء لانشاء منظومه تخصيص 25
سياره اسعاف خاصه بموضوع النقل حالات
المرض الكوفيد 19 بالاضافه الى تخصيص فريق
لدفن
الضحايا مخفف عدد الضحايا حقيقه وخفف عدد
الاصابات في في شمال غرب سوريا هلا عدد
الاصابات لم نكن نستطيع تحديده بشكل حقيقي
بعدم بسبب عدم وجود مراكز او مخابر
للتحليل البي سي ار وعدم وجود كيتات
للاجراء عمليات التحليل ولكن عدد نحن
استطيع ان اقول بانه كان عدد اقل او الذر
او المشاكل اقل بما بسبب كوفي 19 بسبب انه
المنطقة هي اصلا منطقه محاصره ولا يدخلها
ولا
نعم الحركه هي داخليه
الذين يدخل يعني انا لا استذكر حاليا
ارقام الضحايا ولكن كان ممكن يصل الزلزال
الذي تعرضت له تركيا والشمال سوريا والذي
كان كارثيا بشكل استثنائي على تركيا وهي
دوله حديثه وقويه واقتصادها جيد وكانت
النتائج وخيمه جدا وصعبه جدا وما زالت
يعني تركيا تحاول ان تتعافى من هذه
الكارثه فما بالك بحال السوريين وهم
يعيشون كارثه دائما وجاءتهم هذه الكارثه
الاستثنائيه شخصنا واقع هذه المناطق
السوريه في الزلزال حقيقه كانت ماساه
كبيره جدا في تركيا وفي سوريا كون سوريا
اصلا كبلد هي غير
مستعده او غير مجهزه على الزلازل ولكن
يعني
دعني يعني ما ميزت استجابه الخوز البيضاء
في الزلزال هو نحن عندما تلقينا تدريبات
تلقينا تدريبات في تركيا من منظمه تركيا
كانت على الاستجابه للزلازل
فهذا اعطانا يعني خبره بهذا المجال ومن
خلال عفوا ماذا يحتاج المنقذوه للدفاع
المدني لاستجابه يعني مجموع الخبرات او
عناوين للخبرات يعني هلا اولا هو انت يعني
يجب ان يكون لديك خبرات في موضوع خبرات
اولا كيف تستطيع ان تبني نفق داخل البناء
يعني يمكن الركب ان ينزل الركام فانت تسمع
صوت على بعد عشره امتار لكن يعني اي حركه
للانقاض ممكن ان تقضي على هذا الشخص لذلك
يكون هناك بناء نفق نفق مصغر على شكل نفق
ويتم تدعيمه مع بخطوات
نعم يتم تدعيمه حتى تصل الى
المعدات وهذا بحاجه الى معدات وبحاجه الى
الامر اللي نحن فقدناه في حقيقه في
الزلزال هو عدم توفر معدات تقنيه عاليه
هذه المعدات التقنيه نحن عندما وصلنا الى
مناطق الزلزال ويعني نحن وصلنا مناطق
زلزال بعد خمس دقائق بدات فرق ما تنتشر في
المناطق التي تعرضت وين بتحديد المناطق في
جنديرس وفي حارم وسلقين وكفر تخاريم
وارمناز والتقييم اول تقييم حقيقه كان لم
يكن الامور واضحه بالنسبه لنا كثيرا في في
الفجر يعني عندما خرجت الفرق انا طلبت
منهم تفقد المناطق والمدن كل المراكز
تفقدت بدات تاتي التقارير بانه هناك ابنيه
منهاره هناك جدران منهاره ولكن عندما
يعني بدات ضوء النهار يطلع والشمس تشرق
تيجي بدات تاتي الاخبار المفجعه حقيقه
والاخبار الكبيره لذلك ولكن نحن منذ بدايه
يعني انا عندما لاحظت قوه الزلزال على
الاخبار قبل ان نعرف مدى حجم الدمار طلبت
فعليا بعد عشر دقائق اعلنت حاله الطوارئ
وطلبت كافه العاملين بالدفاع المدني ان
يلتحقوا باماكن عملهم او ان يلتحق باقرب
مركز موجود ليلتحف بالعمل ونشرنا 2500 شخص
كان في الميدان وكان هناك دعم لوجستي كبير
وعندما قيمنا الوضع بشكل حقيقي وشاهدنا
نقص في الاليات ونقص في المعدات اطلقت
نداء استغاثه
وطلبت اليات وطلبت معدات اول من استجاب
حقيقه هو الشعب السوري يعني هناك كثير من
الشركات الانشاءات وال
مقابل اليات الثقيله اتوا الينا ووضعوا
مفاتيح الياتهم وقالوا كل الياتنا هي تحت
تصرفكم وحقيقه حاله التضامن الكبير التي
ظهرت عند اهلنا في سوريا وفي كل مكان في
العالم كانوا يدعمون العمل ويقدمون
الشعبيه جيده في السعوديه في الكويت وفي
كل العالم في الدول بشكل لكن هذه حملات
شعبيه رسميه بشكل مباشر
بعدها حقيقه كان هناك استجابه من الدول
بعد
فاول كان هناك تواصل من قبل كثير من
الحكومات معنا بشكل مباشر
وقدموا الدعم امريكا بريطانيا فرنسا
الدنمارك وايضا
سنتحدث عن الامم المتحده قريبا ولكن قطر
هي كانت ايضا من اول الدول التي تواصلت
معنا وكانت من اول الدول التي ارسلت
المساعده للخوذ البيضاء حتى نستطيع تقديم
اهلنا موضوع الامم المتحده حقيقه ان هذا
امر مختلف يعني وانا يعني يعني ساتحدث عنه
بشكل مفصل حقيقه الامم المتحده هي لم تقوم
بدورها الحقيقي يعني اولا الامم المتحده
لم تعلن حاله الطوارئ في شمال غرب سوريا
بسبب الزلزال وكان هناك يعني
واعترف السيد مارتن جريفيس بفشل الامم
المتحده الاستجابه لهذا الزلزال لذلك يعني
انا كنت انتظر من الامم المتحده وصرحت
كثيرا عن هذا الامر باجراء تحقيق شفاف
لمحاسبه المقصرين لانه هناك موظفين مقصرين
القائم مثلا باعمال الامين العام في دمشق
السيد
بلمليح في اليوم الثالث للزلزال تحدث الى
الوكاله تسانا في دمشق ولم يتحدث عن
الزلزال في ادلب وجنديرس ومناطق اخرى
مقصرين
يعني انا استطيع ان اقول هناك امرين هو
دبل لدينا دبل ستاندرد في التعامل يعني
معايير مزدوجه بالعمل وبنفس الوقت هناك
تقصير وبيروقراطيه قاتلي بعمليات
الاستجابه ولذلك انا عندما اجتمعت مع
مسؤولين بالام تحدي طالبتهم بمراجعه اليات
العمل في سوريا وهم بداوا يراجعون بعض
الالات وبدات فرق من الام تحدي تذهب الى
شمال غرب سوريا وتقوم بدولات الميدانيه
اتمنى ان نساعد هذا الامر ولكن نحن سنستمر
بالمطالبه باجراء هذا التحقيق الشفاف
سنستمر بالمطالبه بالتغيير اليه الاستجابه
لانه يكفي الاستجابه الطارئه يعني دائما
عشر سنوات والامم بتحدي قيم وتلل اغاثيه
نحن بحاجه الى تنميه نحن بحاجه الى مشاريع
قادره ان تؤمن فرص عمل للناس في المخيمات
هذا ما يؤمن هذا ما يساعد الناس على
الاستقرار هذا ما يساعد الناس على بناء
بالتفكير بانه يجب ماذا استقرار يحتاج الى
وجود ايراد اداره سياسيه ايضا يعني ولكن
يعني نحن لا نستطيع ان نستمر الى عشرات
سنوات بتقديم خيام وسلا الاغاثيه ان يعني
انت هنا تخلق حالي من اقتصاد الحرب هذا
جزء يؤثر على بنيه سوريا الاقتصاديه في
المستقبل كانه في حاجه لتغيير استراتيجي
في العمل نحن بحاجه الى تغيير طبعا نشات
نحن بحاجه باليات التعامل نحن بحاجه الى
تفكير بشكل مختلف بموضوع الدعم الذي يقدم
للزلزال كانه فتح بوابه لنظام دمشق لاعاده
تاهيل نفسه دوليا وبدا الحديث عن مساعدات
النظام في دمشق طبعا هناك مسائل داخليه
ولكن تم توظيفها لا شك انه نحن يعني مع
وصول المساعدات لاهلنا المتضررين بحلب
وبلاذقيه وجبلي والمناطق التي تحصلت
النظام ونحن كنا نالم عندما نعلم بانه لا
بان النظام لا يعني كان غير جدي في عمليه
انقاذ المدنيين في من تحت الانقاض وهذا
يعني وصلتني انا مناشدات من حلب ومن
اللاذقيه ومن مناطق اخرى ولكن وطالبت
السيد مارتن جريفيس حتى انه اذا امن طريق
لا فرق القوه البيضاء ليذهبوا الى مناطق
انتحت حمايه دولي فنحن سنذهب الى حلب
واللاذقي لنساعد المدنيين تحت الانقاض فهم
يعني النظام السوري عبر عشر سنوات اثبت
فشله في اداره الملفات واثبت فشله في
اداره الكوارث وهو خبير بالقتل ولكن ليس
خبير بانقاذ الارواح موضوع الاستغلال
الازمه السياسيا حقيقه هذا كان امر معين
جدا يعني معيب في في اللحظه التي نحن
الناس تعيش ماساه الناس احنا كنا هنا يجب
ان نعمل فقط على تقديم الاغاثه العاجل
تقديم اغاثه طارئه تامين ما هو العاجل بعد
الزلزال لا يجب ان ان كان ان يفكر احد في
موضوع الاستغلال ولكن النظام دائما ما
استغل جراح السوريين دائما مستغله
والحقيقه من ساعده على استغلال هذا الامر
هو الامم المتحده لماذا لان الامم المتحده
يعني دعني اقول هذه المعلومات وهي معلومات
لاول مره انا اتكلم بها
في اليوم الثاني
للزلزال كان نائب السيد مارتن جريس موجود
في دمشق ويفاوض النظام السوري
على فتح المعابر لارسال المساعدات لكن
النظام لليوم الرابع رفض
رفض رفض قطعي ولكن عندما اصبح هناك نحن
كنا نتواصل دوليا عندما كان هناك نقاش عن
انه ستفتح المعابر غصبا عن اي احد راح
يرفض في مجلس الامن وكان هناك اجتماع
لمجلس الامن وروسيا تلقت هذه الرساله من
دول كثيره من العالم بانه
سنرسل المساعدات ان قبلتم وان رفضتم ولن
نعترف بقرار مجلس الامن بعد ذلك روسيا هنا
شعرت بانها ستخسر ورقه سياسيه من يدها
يتفاوض الدول الغربيه بشكل مستمر عليها
فاتصلت في بشار الاسد على ما اعتقد وقالت
له اقبل فتح المعابر للام المتحده وبعدها
حقيقه كان مؤسف ليخرج السيد الامين العام
ويتحدث بانه يشكر بشار الاسد ويقول له
ثانكيو متر برزدنت هذه عمليه يعني تجميل
تجميل تقريبا ودعني اقول وانا قلت لهم
يعني كنت في حديث في احد المسؤولي
اول بند في العمل الانساني هو يجب ان لا
يتاذى المستفيد لا جسديا ولا نفسيا وحقيقه
الامم المتحده عندما تقوم بهذا العمل بهذا
الشكل هي تخرق اول مبدا بالعمل الانساني
لانه هناك
خمس مليون انسان يعيشون من شمال غير سوريا
هم هجرهم النظام السوري ابنائهم معتقلون
وهم يشكرون بشار الاسد ويطلبون موافقته
لارسال المساعدات لهم نهايه الحلقه اريد
ان اسالك عن امرين يعني
انتج فيلم في نتفليكس عن عن الخوض البيضاء
وهذا يعني امر ذو دلاله بمعنى ان هناك
نمذجه وهناك اهتمام بهذه التجربه انت
حضرتك اخترت من اهميه شخصيه في 2017 ايضا
كا احد الناشطين في عمليات الدفاع المدني
هذا امر يعني يثير الاعجاب من حيث التجربه
المدنيه التي اسست في ظروف صعبه
كيف اثر عليكم هذه النظره هذا الاهتمام
الاعلامي فقط بعيدا عن الدعم المادي هلا
لا شك انه يعني
عندما يتم الاختيارك بهذا المكان وتصوير
فيلم والحصول لهذا الفيلم على جائزه
الاوسكار كافضل فيلم وثائقي
بتلك السنه هذا اثر على صوره
هو صوره الخوذ البيضاء صوره الدفاع المدني
بانه هذه المؤسسه هي فعليا تخضع لمعايير
عاليه من العمل ومن المصداقيه ومن
الموثوقي فنحن نمتلك اليه حوكمه داخليه
تستطيع ان تضبط كل العمليات وان تعمل
بشفافيه مطلقه وان تكسب ولديها القدره على
كسب ثقه ليس فقط
امتلك القدره كسبت سقط المؤسسات الدوليه
بموضوع الدعم بالاضافه من خلال الصدق
والاماني بخدمه اهلها في سوريا استطاعت ان
تكسب ثقه المدني في سوريا صاحب هذه الخوذه
البيضاء رائد الصالح والاف من شباب السوري
شبابا
وكبارا وصغار العاملين في هذه المنظمه
والذي نواجهوا اشرس عمليه اشرس حرب حقيقه
استهدفت المدنيين عبر القصف عبر الاستهداف
الكيماوي عبر القد القتل المتعمد والبشع
والمزدوج شكرا جزيلا لك منحتنا هذا الوقت
للحديث عن جانب من هذه التجربه تجربه هذه
الخوذه التي يعتز فيها السوريين واعتز
فيها كل انسان شاهد هذا الموقف في وجه اله
القتل التي لم تتوقف طوال 12 سنه من الان
شكرا جزيلا لك شكرا جزيلا الشكر موصل لكم
انتم مشاهدينا الكرام على طيب المتابعه
الاسبوع القادم ان شاء الله يجمعنا لقاء
اخر في المقابله دمتم بخير وفي امان الله
[موسيقى]